well this is a different view I'm
usually sitting all the way on the other
side of this room and now I'm sitting
here on this side of the room good
morning John it's Tetris day
what does Tetris day I wanted to show
you guys this is a birthday present from
I've forgotten who hold on it was from
Helen Thank You Helen
today is Tetris day because together
we're going to do an awesome touch with
related thing right now for those of you
who've been participating in the email
version of this project that's right
there's stuff going on behind the scenes
if you've sent stuff in already it's
definitely going to get used but we need
more we need a lot more now many of you
might know that I wrote a Tetris song
once it called the man who threw the
tetris piece I played it on my acoustic
guitar and an awesome nerdfighter named
Bill Martin who is dr. noise do ctor
noise he covered the song in a sort of
hardcore fashion cue music
so that's gonna be the background of the
whole video so you can listen to it I'll
bill and I have decided that we were to
make a nerd fight a stick music video
for his version of the tetris view song
and we need your help we need your help
we need your help really bad we're all
gonna create Tetris pieces in our own
houses Tetris pieces are all composed of
squares each one has four squares the
squares in these touches pieces will be
about eight inches
nothing has to be perfect here really
don't be perfect be fast be awesome be
creative and be excited you gotta create
the tetris pieces and the nerdfighters
from all over the world will pretend
like they're playing Tetris and then
suddenly from out of their TV will pop
these Tetris pieces now I'm gonna show
you an example of how this might look
you can do it your own way but this is
how kappa denied
now I'm gonna show you how to make the
tetris pieces scissors tape of some kind
of video camera tape measurers good a
straightedge construction paper of very
cars turkey also it occurs to me that
you will need permission from your
parents to use the knife don't stain any
of your belongings with
once you've got your tuchis video
finished please send it to dr. noise at
gmail.com the deadline for submissions
is June 14 June 14 finishes by June 14
in addition to playing Tetris and
getting hit by tetris pieces there are
some other things that you can do we're
trying to do lip-syncing for the whole
song but instead of having everyone
memorize the whole song we decided to
use a mathematical formula to determine
what people are saying what verses so if
you are going to do a video check out
the lyrics in the sidebar along with a
fairly basic mathematical formula that
will tell you which verse to memorize
and sing while you're playing Tetris
slash dancing slash getting up in the
face the cameras laughing in general
shocked and disturbed and frustrated
with the tenacity of the tetris man
thank you to everyone who can
participates but thank you to bill for
making the excellent song and thank you
to Russia for making Tetris and also the
tetris song which thankfully is a folk
melody and that's not protected under US
copyright whoo nerdfighters John I will
see you soon